remember we're the Guinness fresh here
right now information between two things
is one then that basically means the two
things are the same size at least
roughly so if you got small angles if
you're dealing with tiny tiny thin
angles okay that means that for small
feet are okay this tells me that sine
theta and theta the actual values should
be about the same right like that's what
that means the ratio being one in
exactly the same way for a small theta
again 10 V naught and V are also about
the same now this guy down here cosine
is different right it's behaving in a
different way but I can still get a
small angular behavior very easy out of
it namely that cause they dog I'm gonna
be roughly not feed off but one because
that's where the limit is going now how
do I use that how do I take advantage
okay if you have any question that
involves measurement and it has some
kind of small theta like a degree or one
of the half degrees or something like
that you can approximate your answer
using this and you never need to appeal
to any trig ratios okay let me give you
an example if you've got a towel arm
since 1512 it is away from me and
because it's so far away it doesn't
break I measured a living condition an
angle of elevation it's one degree okay
I actually sorry I think the number of
shows was 18 no see what if you know
you're 18 kilometres away like your GPS
is something you measure angle of
elevation okay what does this look like
well we would really really far away
like this he's that distance that you
are away from the tower this is what I'm
trying to work out here that's called H
for height and there is my angle of
elevation now remembering that I do tend
to like measure things in degrees all of
this only functions in radians
that's how this all was born okay so the
first thing they do has a good to
convert that what's one degree in
radians it's gonna be so remembering the
time on in radians is 180 degrees I want
one degree of peace all divided by hug
lady tonight gives me PI on 180 radians
okay yes now have a look at this
triangle right there's a simple
connection between H and this distance
that we know is the unknown is to learn
its tail
tan of this angle that's high on hunter
named radiance should be opposite what a
Jason repairing that H on 18 corners but
because theta the angle is so very small
10 theta and theta are about the same
like for small angles that's what's
happening so therefore I can substitute
this for applying on hundred eighty
right then say I'm approximately equal
to that these two for small theta are
behaving the same way no evaluation look
like so now all I have to do is multiply
through by a team now gives me PI on 10
that's zero point three one four one
five
now I hold on a second what units
kilometres look the greatest student for
measuring buildings right or talent so
I'm going to convert this to his more
suitable units such as meters so this is
kilometers so what I've got here is
three I've got a thousand meters a
thousand be expected right so this is
three hundred and fourteen point let's
round off okay because you think that's
ridiculous
the only country that talked for seven
points 305 not to be sure so you can see
here I can take advantage of these
ratios and their limits in this way now
by the way just let me quickly draw you
a picture of what this means right
do you remember we had the certainly i
knew i comparing sine theta with feet
are what that's comparing really is sine
theta is this length view at the
straight line right and feet off is the
arc length right and of course when
theta is very very small be quad and we
are pretty much the same it's a
right because they get closer and get
some easy